The day just ended for someone.
And the day just started for somebody.
In empty streets I walked about
Confessing my boredom out loud.
I wanna keep feeling it
But you won't forget about this
Knock Three Times, before requesting.
I wanna keep touching it
Trouble's no longer a thing
When a future
You just waved to me.
I wanna keep feeling it
But you won't forget about this
Knock Three Times, before requesting.
I wanna keep touching it
Trouble's no longer a thing
When a future
You just waved to me.
A Day We Love Best
Ladies and gentlemen!
On this most celebrated day,
we, the loving friends and family of
our dearest Lady Zhu have gathered to celebrate her birthday.
Before we get this gala going, allow me to introduce myself.
Inviting you was difficult.
The Don doesn't like the Rat King's monopoly on this medicine.
Why don't you help us make this medicine too?
This is none of my business!
HELP!
Sorry for the wait. Up next, let's welcome Lady Zhu
with a big round of applause!
Thank you all for coming!
Now, please enjoy the performances that we have prepared for you.
Take him away.
Did you see their boss?
No.
Did you see Aak?
I dunno.
We should watch a play together next time!
Sure!
Is this the place?
Aak? Where are you?
We finally meet.
Rat King.
How are you doing?
Feels good to have everyone in your pockets, doesn't it?
You have every Lungmen gang working for you.
Then you tie us down with unreasonable work!
I've been watching you for a while.
I shall end your existence today!
Hand over Aak to us!
Rat King.
Not everyone gets to see the real Rat King!
WHAT?!
You took the bait,
dimwit.
Let's catch the cat.
Must we speak in four words now?
Hot is this bodybag.
Jeeze, quit it.
What a lousy plan!
You *LUNGMEN* *EXPLETIVE*
Ji-ji-ru-lu-ling!
SAVE MEEEEE!!!
I didn't expect this disguise.
What Cat Mafia?
He's not even a cat.
Don Felino is still at large.
Nonetheless, we still carried out your task.
It's alright.
We revealed his true form.
The fake Cat Mafia is no more.
How fares the young man?
I QUIT! This job is too tiring for me!
We can go start a restaurant!
Just get some sleep. We'll make more money tomorrow.
I'M LEAVING LUNGMEN TOMORROW!
Long-term request: The Rat King wanted Lee's D.A
to find out more about the Cat Mafia's Don.
If this Don is a fraud, then reveal his true identity
and take down his fake organization.
(See you again)